if you didn't name a sandwich what would  be in it it was Bobby lay and be racist  I don't care give us the full just be  real be real if you were forced to make  the Bobby Lee sandwich what would be in  it come  oh what type of bread what kind of bread  all right so because it's a cup of  coffee  it's a plate of calm right no bread will  we bake our own bread it would be on our  bread all right so not a specialized  bread  no no we use the same we we bake our own  bread we're very proud of our bread okay  so you're bread but you would just  become on it and that would be called  the Bobby Lane yeah no one would ever  buy it no of course not yeah Dad you  need some of this  foreign